>> Geraldo: THAT WAS MY THEME
SONG.
GETTING MOCKED AND CRITICIZED
ONCE AGAIN AFTER DISHING OUT
ANOTHER ONE OF HER NOW
NOTORIOUSLY SCRAMBLED RESPONSES
WHICH ARE CRITICS HAVE TAKEN TO
CALLING A WORD SALAD, THE
VICE PRESIDENT WAS MEETING WITH
THE JAMAICAN PRIME MINISTER FOR
EXAMPLE WHEN SHE LEARNED OF THIS
OUT.
>> JAMAICA ONE OF THE ISSUES
THAT HAS BEEN PRESENTED AS AN
ISSUE WHICH IS ECONOMIC IN THE
WAY THE IMPACT DURING THE
PANDEMIC.
SO TO THAT END, WE ARE
ANNOUNCING THAT THEY ALSO THAT
WE WILL ASSIST JAMAICA AND
COVERT RECOVERY BY ASSISTING IN
TERMS OF THE RECOVERY AND
JAMAICA THAT HAS BEEN ESSENTIAL
TO BELIEVE WHAT IS NECESSARY TO
STRENGTHEN NOT ONLY THE ISSUE A
PUBLIC HEALTH, BUT ALSO THE
ECONOMY.
[LAUGHS]
>> Geraldo: SHE JUST HAD THE
APPS.
>> Dana: I DON'T THINK SO
UNEVEN WITH THE GIBBS R.
>> Geraldo: DOMINIC IF THAT IS
THE CASE HOW DO YOU BECOME WE
GET TO BE WHERE YOU ARE THE
>> Dana: BASICALLY IT ENDS UP
LOOKING LIKE THE BOTTOM OF THE
MISSISSIPPI GOES IN LIKE 40
DIFFERENT DIRECTIONS IT'S
IMPOSSIBLE TO DO.
ALL SHE HAD TO DO TO NOT BE
CONSIDERED THE WORST
VICE PRESIDENT IN HISTORY IS
NOTHING.
DO NO HARM THAT IS ROLE THE
VICE PRESIDENT IF YOU CAN HELP
GREAT BUT DON'T CAUSE ANY
PROBLEMS, DON'T BE SOMEBODY THAT
CAN BE BASICALLY LAMPOONED.
IF THE OWNER OF
"SATURDAY NIGHT LIVE" WILL DO
SOME ABOUT THIS JUDGE.
>> Geraldo: ESSAY AGAIN LAST
WEEK.
>> Dana: THIS WILL BE 30 VICE
PRESIDENTS IN HISTORY THAT ARE
NUMBERED BY ANYTHING IN A
TOTALLY FINE WITH THAT.
I'M AFRAID IN THE SITUATION I
DON'T SEE HOW THIS CAN GET ANY
BETTER.
>> Geraldo: FOR THE CURRENT
VICE PRESIDENT?
>> Greg: HOW OLD DO I LOOK?
YOU KNOW THAT HOLD HIM AGAINST
THAT ALL THE TIME.
[LAUGHS]
HE MADE A TERRIBLE DOCTOR CAN
YOU IMAGINE THE DIAGNOSIS?
YOU KNOW, HARRIS NEEDS?
SHE NEEDS A SIGNIFICANT PASSAGE
OF TIME IN BETWEEN HER GAPS SO
THAT THERE ARE MORE SIGNIFICANT
PATCHES OF TIMES BETWEEN HER
GAPS THERE ARE SIGNIFICANT GIVEN
THE INSIGNIFICANT PASSAGE OF
TIME.
AN ALGORITHM LIKE A SENSE
GENERATOR WE JUST INSERT 4-5
WORDS AND SEE WHAT YOU GET A MIC
YOU DO ALL DAY.
YES.
A BIBLICAL REFERENCE.
>> Geraldo: NEEDING THE ESCAPE
GOAT FOR THE JOE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION.
>> Jesse: WHO CARES GERALDO
HIM AND HELP HER AND SHE NEEDS
HELP RIGHT NOW.
SHE JUST SAYING THAT YOU WANT
THE COUNTRY TO HELP JAMAICA
AFTER JAMAICA I'M TEN TO HELP
ECONOMICALLY.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO SAY WAS 70
WORDS I HEAR WHAT'S GOING ON.
SHE'S NOT COMFORTABLE WITH
HERSELF, SHE'S A PROSECUTOR
SHE'S NOT A POLITICIAN.
SPEAK LIKE A PROSECUTOR, GET TO
THE POINT, PROSECUTORS JUST NAIL
IT THEY DON'T HAVE TO SOUND LIKE
A DIPLOMAT LIKE LINCOLN OR
MAYOR PETE WHICH SPEECH IS LIKE
A BUREAUCRAT WE DON'T TALK LIKE
THAT, JUST BE YOURSELF, SHOOT
STRAIGHT, SPEAK FROM THE HEART
BUT SHE IS HANDED WORDS AND
SENTENCES THAT ARE GOBBLING LUBE
FROM HIS YOUNG 30-YEAR-OLDS,
MASTER DEGREES AND SHE'S JUST
READING IT AND SHE'S TRYING TO
BE SOMEONE SHE'S NOT.
SHE NEEDS TO TAKE A LITTLE HIKE,
MAYBE TAKE A FEW DAYS OFF, MAYBE
A VACATION, FIND YOURSELF AND
THEN RE-CENTER AND COME BACK.
YOU KNOW HE CAN GET A
PSYCHEDELIC EXPERIENCE.
THAT'S WHY LOOKED AT YOU GREG.
>> Greg: I'M WELL AWARE AND IT
WORKS.
[LAUGHS]
>> Geraldo: CAN YOU SHOW US?
>> Greg: ALSO YOU LATER.
[LAUGHS]
'S BEFORE I DON'T NEED A
QUESTION, HERE'S THE BOTTOM
LINE.
>> Jeanine: DID THE
VICE PRESIDENT OF UNITED STATES
OF AMERICA, TO ME THE GREATEST
COUNTRY IN THE WORLD.
IT'S NOT HER PEOPLE GIVEN HER
WORD SALAD I WOULD NOT LET THIS
WOMAN OUT OF WHATEVER THE HELL
SHE IS UNLESS SHE COULD WRITE
DOWN ON A PIECE OF PAPER WHAT
SHE IS GOING TO SAY.
SHE SHOULD NOT BAIL THAT OUT,
KAMALA HARRIS WOULD YOU GONNA
SAY?
AND BY THE WAY WHEN I SAW THE
VIDEO SAID ALL THIS MUST BE AN
OLD ONE THIS CAN'T BE NEW.
IT'S NEW, SHE KEEPS COMING OUT
AND EMBARRASSING HERSELF, BUT
SHE IS EMBARRASSING NOT ONLY THE
UNITED STATES, BUT EVERY WOMAN
WHO IS TRY TO GET AHEAD.
PEOPLE IN THE WEST WING